j'ai beaucoup beaucoup de pukki vous
concernant ou qui sait la en cave elle
balance tout sur les chroniqueurs mais
aussi quelqu'un qui a balancé sur vous
il ya une personne de votre entourage
qui nous a donné des dossiers vous
concernant on va sortir ces dossiers un
par un d'accord et à la fin vous allez
essayer de découvrir qui a balancé parmi
vos proches
d'accord ça côté vichy quoi vous pouvez
rien ne pouvait prendre une autre
référence vous vous plairez carrière
fasciné merci on commence avec une
boucle tout cas ce qui vous concerne
tous les deux il paraît que quand vous
avez commencé
vous étiez tellement galère d'argent qui
vous arrive est de démonter les sièges
de votre voiture et de faire une fouille
minutieuse à la recherche de pièces pour
payer le péage mais non c'est quelqu'un
qui le connaît bien parce que ça c'est
vrai c'est vrai quoi vous enlevez les
sièges tout pour y arriver c'est
toujours des rangs quand on est assez
bordélique on est en perdre et toujours
des rondes à la bagnole et souvent ça
nous est arrivé de démonter la bagnole
pour trouver de quoi le soin à personne
ne voulait de nous à paris donc on était
redescendu à toulouse avec la voiture
pleine de nos affaires en dix ans
personne ne veut ne doit pas s'arrêter à
limoges à 2 heures du matin ils étaient
morts de soif je ne sais pas pourquoi on
vous lâche et de l'eau de l'eau
n'importe quoi on a démonté voiture m'a
vidé la voiture sur un parking à
l'entrée de limoges pour trouver une
pièce pour essayer de cacher bien notre
ouïe et on l'a trouvé j'adorerais mais
moi ça veut dire arriver ça aussi au
péage ne pas avoir d'argent au pays mais
mal ils avaient démonté trouvera pas du
tout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
allez ce que vous faites
c'était amoureux une carte m fini non
une reconnaissance de dettes ça
m'arrivait moi j'appuie j'appelle vous
dis mais venant votre numéro
d'immatriculation ils le pren et vous
font reconnaissant le net et vous envoie
ensuite la facture chez vous ouais c'est
ce qui m'est arrivé moi voilà djoudi
il ya longtemps en clair la mairie
grosse galère vous comme ça à
franchement qu'est castaldi ah bah oui
bien sûr mais moi je open j'avais un
truc très bien pour passer sans argent
bah vous déjà le psg voit pratiquement
pas oui mais quand j'étais jeune je le
fais je connais la voiture de devant et
je peux passer sans payer
ah ouais c'est dans la caravane il
m'arrive un truc de ouf aussi un
jugement j'achète une très belle voiture
c'était la prob une belle valbonne les
mots je venais de signer sur ces huit
mois je vous dise achète une belle
voiture une clio et et et jeu et je dis
à mon père mon père sort souvent avec
mon père et mon père on part on décide
de partir tous les deux à deauville et
mon père me dit est ce que je peux
conduire la voiture et mon père conduit
la voiture et sera pas mal
il s'arrête pas aux péages et a pris la
barre hier la voiture maintenant elle
sort du garage sur la tête de ma mère
est excellent pour la barre du péage et
ben c'est pas si lourd que ça bon il ya
une bonne tu vois mais bon mais après tu
sors de me lever
c'est bon c'est rien c'est rien c'est
rien c'est pas grave on n'a pas été
touchée c'est l'essentiel
mais je vous jure que c'est vrai et
c'est quoi cette émission on lui passe
la barrière elle elle paye pas le métro
enfin pardon mais une mission de
délinquants vous avez vous avec tout va
que vous avez fait dans le paf toutes
les franchement à toutes les arnaques
village avec un délabrement calmez-vous
in motion exemple métro bim pass navigo
cas eluana
chez s'est trompé ou voler les oraux des
mois le métro c'est une voiture de sport
c'est sa ré a fait du petit bois et
paris que lorsqu'il était petit francis
à enfermer ses parents et des amis à eux
dans la maison puis il a enterré la clé
dans le jardin et il est parti se cacher
en haut d'un arbre est ce que c'est vrai
ça mais qui sait stand hickman a fait ça
français jeu tetris a annoncé m alors à
coup tu ne sais pas où il est enfermé
ses parents et des amis eux dans la
maison ouais en fait il y avait les clés
mes parents laissait toujours lesquels
sur la pointe a évidemment il y avait
des amis que à mes parents qui met un
qui m'a supporté et je vais à l'enfermer
dedans et j'avais enterré les clés au
fond du jardin
c'est à carreaux pour leur dire c'est
maintenant et après je suis allé me
mettre sur une broche n'a obligé d'aller
chercher une échelle me descend jamais
pris une année tu adores ce cas je suis
fan
je me suis calmé t'as du print a dû
prendre je connais j'ai un copain qui
avait ça en passant le le permis de
conduire il monte le mec y avait grève
des inspecteurs donc dans ces cas là à
l'époque y mettez des militaires pour
les remplacer pas des mecs très cool
quoi l'autre ils arrivent avec les
cheveux l'a éconduit et le buggy ça vous
gêne pas les cheveux par regard des
rétroviseurs lui il enlève la clé 10 et
tacle et aurait besoin connard ils
achètent dans la rivière
[Applaudissements]
cette année que vous ayez pris part aux
parents moi moi moi moi j'ai eu une
tannée moi comme ça un jour j'avais fais
quoi moi je me rappelle moi c'est moi
j'étais un débile moi en fait en fait
j'étais avec des copains et des copines
et chez moi ou jouer un truc
j'avais on prenait des chaussettes et on
ouvrait un tiroir et on jouait au street
basket ça veut dire dès qu'on voit là
dès qu'on mettait une la chaussette
on brasse tablier et quand on a loupé le
tiroir on devait enlever un truc et donc
ma mère un jour la rive dans la 100è
nous a eu des copains et des copines
pratiquement tous à wall elle sera bonne
et elle m'a défoncé mon cas une belle
histoire parce qu'il faut voir la scène
tu vois avec le tiroir et nous ont joué
vraiment mais très salée on est à fond
oui mais voilà et dont tu parles
montaigne g printer à quoi ma mère
acheter des martinis à l'époque ça
existe et moi je savais où elle planqué
donc j'allais avec des ciseaux couper
les lanières dons et prêts de martin et
pourtant il y avait plus d avenir et
l'agent trop nul mais avec les mains
c'est votre mère vous frappez martinez
ah oui et non c'est pas les parents
parce que lui lui sa mère à le frapper
mais martinez à l'automne
[Applaudissements]
ça commence on n'a pas dessus et tu
attends quand il était en galère
d'argent eric avait troqué son blouson
en cuir en échange d'un trajet en
voiture c'est vrai c'est moi pas
exactement ça ces mois passés à côté
quand on a débuté à un moment on était
venu à paris avec un camion qui avait un
trou dans le réservoir
ça on avait à peu près 12 km d'autonomie
vous et le plein toutes les 10 minutes
pour avancer bombay et de qu'on était
vraiment n'avait rien et on était venu
faire un espèce de spectacle gratuit qui
devait nous déclencher plein de trucs et
qui nous a rien déclenché évidemment non
et francis devait rester à paris pour
une école de jazz qu'est ce qui était
batteur mais on n'avait rien et alors
été dans un parking souterrain dans le
xviie là moi j'allais repartir à
toulouse avec les musiciens perdre tout
le monde était fauché et je vois francis
et que ces deux baguettes de batterie
dans ce parking franche chance que moi
ça m'a fendu le coeur ouais je faisais
mais je peux rien j'ai rien qu'est ce
qu'on fait et se vendait lui revient il
me dit ça t'intéresse pas mon blouson
chez moi on n'a pas la même taille
j'ai dit ça m'intéresse pas mais bon il
a vraiment rien donc je vais acheter son
blouson s'emballe
ah ouais c'est kim arriver là et puis on
l'a laissé à paris dans sa parodie c'est
de vous et je vous ai vus j'ai des
bonnes infos qu à l âme et une vraie
balance petite dernière francis est
surnommé sushi par certaines personnes
on ne sait pas si c
préc suel ouais bon pourquoi ah ouais ça
c'est mal c'est ma fille qui m'appelle
comme ça à sushis à vous appeler le
sushi proverbe on en sushi bâ parce que
je suis passé affectif ça fait très
longtemps je pense qu'on a dû aller
manger des japonais quelque part et
tuchan le saumon saké m'étonne s'il y
avait ma fille qui m'appelle vous avez
une fille ouais une fille et que sa
belle clara carraway à la 24e c'est ça
elle est comédienne basse et elle lape
ou qui regardent bayik c'est moi qui
vous ai cave
je voulais pas balancer mais faut pas
m'en vouloir ils m'ont proposé beaucoup
d'argent granby a été très très sympa